[Music]
I'll welcome to the podcast I have to
say before I read your book I listen to
your your interview your your interview
your appearance on your husband's
podcast and it's so funny because he
says welcome to the podcast and then you
just start giggling right and then he
says so Annika I probably remember it
better than tell me about the book and
then you just go really look that's the
question you're gonna ask and I just
immediately felt like oh I'm all in on
just like taking the piss out of him I
thought that was very nice so yeah and I
love the book congratulations on it
making the New York Times bestseller
list is very cool and I'm excited to
talk to you this is a fascinating
subject yeah I think so subject the more
that you think about it the more sort of
amazing and wonderful and mystifying it
becomes right yeah so before we kind of
delve into consciousness why don't we
contextualize this a little bit how did
you get interested in this field I also
I just wanted to ask you though is this
something you're interested in before
you read my book er was it have you been
thinking about it since reading it
well I asked just because they're the
category of people who are have just
been fascinated with it always and then
everyone seems to become fascinated with
it once they learn a little but it's
impossible to not be fascinated by it
once you start to learn a little bit
about it right I would say that I have a
an interest in it that is long-standing
although I don't know that that it rose
to the level of you know obsession like
it's not that
but through my journeys and in addiction
recovery and then being introduced to
meditation and yoga and various
spiritual practices and certainly become
more and more interesting so yeah yeah
so actually I became interested in
meditation I think mostly because of my
fascination with consciousness
but they're obviously related so as I
said it was a lifelong fascination it's
something I've just always been
interested in and want you know as I got
older read a lot about and then for the
last almost 15 years I've been working
with scientists who write for the
general public I've been doing mostly
editing but some coaching for TED talks
and things like that and so I got
actually deeper into the neuroscience
and I have I basically have just for my
because of my own interest been taking
notes all of this time for myself
and a few maybe like two and a half
years ago I started really formally
writing not really for any purpose
except to think through my own thoughts
because I was interested and I felt like
the but the topic is so complex I needed
to do some writing just to sort out for
myself
where I was with all of it and what I
thought could be true but my so my book
is really the the science and philosophy
of consciousness and I tried to make it
as accessible as possible which was
really the main goal and I I'm focused
on kind of consciousness what the most
fundamental aspect or consciousness in
the most fundamental sense and why it's
so deeply mysterious why it's so
difficult for neuroscientists to study
it why it just always has been
perplexing to scientists so I walk the
reader through what I think are some of
the most interesting theories and
research and consciousness studies but
this is all kind of in the context of
challenging our intuitions right about
what consciousness is yeah it's it's not
it's less about drawing any specific
conclusions right yeah and it is about
let's confront what we think it is and
deconstruct that a little bit I think us
realize that it's so much more complex
and fast and confounding
inspiring and yeah one of the great
mysteries so yeah so I kind of part of
me just wanted to spread that the idea
that this is one of the great mysteries
and if you haven't discovered it yet
it's like as its as fun to contemplate
as the idea of black holes or the you
know the beginning of the universe or
all the things that we that we pretty
easily understand our great mysteries
and interesting to come right from black
holes all the way down to particle
physics right yeah yeah and that this
actually fits in with with some of the
mysteries that pop up there as well so
yeah so so challenging intuitions is
something that I think is incredibly
interesting and it's a very important
part of the scientific process which I
think most people know but they don't
really think about or realize that every
time we make a scientific breakthrough
or understand reality at a more
fundamental level or reach a deeper
truth about the nature of reality that
always requires that we challenge our
intuitions at the very least sometimes
we have to completely let go of
intuitions that are actually giving us
false information about reality so this
is true and everything from
understanding that the earth is a sphere
and not flat as our senses lead us to
believe and you know this actually took
a lot of science to to get enough
information to realize that our
intuitions were wrong celestial
observations that convinced people over
a long period of time because it was it
was it's so counterintuitive it's
actually hard for people right once they
get their minds around once the science
is hard and fast there's still an
extraordinarily extraordinarily long lag
period before people who still adopt it
yes and that's true for scientists it's
kind of like the scientists come first
that but there's always this period of
time of wrestling with intuitions before
the scientists first are kind of able to
accept the evidence that has come in
that's counter to our intuitions and
then the public obviously comes a little
bit later but that's you know the germ
theory of disease is another great
example that I like to give that the
idea that microscopic things that we
can't interact with or sense at all can
kill us you know is there something that
took people a long time to see enough
evidence for right that they could
accept it scientists priding themselves
on their objective lens are still you
know held prisoner by our own cognitive
biases well absolutely and it's part of
a scientific process we have to kind of
check everything against our intuitions
but it and it is just this process of
checking and checking and saying no you
know that can't be right that informed
that just it feels so wrong it can't be
right and then you can fight you finally
get to a point where you start to shift
your intuitions or you learn how to just
not trust them in that particular area
in the case of consciousness though I
feel like after reading this book were
barely out of the starting gate yes so
that was that was why I was one of the
main reasons I wrote this book and
really the goal of the book is to shake
up our intuitions about consciousness as
much as possible because I think if we
are able to make progress if we're able
to and the human brain I think is not
capable of understanding everything and
so it may just fall into that category
but if we can understand consciousness
better it will require that we that we
really challenge some strong intuitions
that we have and I think we're at that
point with regard to consciousness I
like that you say that the human brain
isn't capable of understanding all of
these things I feel like there's a cubic
Flair that that kind of emanates across
the scientific community then that that
that we can indeed understand everything
and perhaps that's true at some future
point or with the I think it's a I think
it's interesting cuz most science I know
and and typically scientists more than
other people I know are much more
willing to say they don't know something
or we may never know or you know this is
this is deeply mysterious physicists in
particular but scientists in general I
think the messaging that comes out and I
would partly fault the media but I think
it's also just at a natural circumstance
of the messaging when we learn something
new it's
kind of declared as if we we know all
these things and everything is knowable
right but I don't actually think that's
the stance well particularly with
physicists I mean the more you do I mean
it's like it's like how do you even
begin to understand what these things
I've been watching these wonderful
videos of this physicist nema our Connie
Hamed who's brilliant and hard to
understand but I do my best but he
spends most of his time talking about
how space-time is no longer something
that we think is fundamental that
there's something that's more
fundamental that space-time that
basically there is no at a fundamental
level there is no space and time so yeah
I mean therefore we're never gonna get
our minds around that even if we can
believe it well time is a is a is a is a
focus of the book and in the later
chapters and I want to get to that but
let's start with let's just let's just
define our terms like we're talking
about consciousness like what do we
actually mean so people do use the word
many different ways and it's confusing
the way I'm using the word in the book
and what I think most people mean when
they're talking about the mystery of
consciousness the kind of them
consciousness in the most fundamental
sense is the closest word I can get to
his experience and I use Thomas Nagel
description of consciousness from his
essay called what it is like to be a bat
which is a great essay and I recommend
from from the 70s and he says in that
essay an organism is conscious if there
is something that it is like to be that
organism and that language for a lot of
people they kind of get it right away I
actually for me that happened I I knew
exactly what he meant but the language
really isn't very precise and it can be
confusing so I usually follow that up
with a series of questions especially
for someone who's just says I don't I
don't know what that means to say it's
it's like something and so I'll say is
is there something that it's like to be
you right now and I run through this in
the book and of course whoever I'm
asking week we all know we're having an
X
aryans right we're conscious and we're
having an experience and then is there
something that it's like to be this book
on the table and our intuitive answer is
no and despite what's actually true in
the world the fact that we can imagine a
collection of matter in the universe
that entails no experience at all the
lights are not on from the inside right
that's non conscious material and then a
collection of matter in the universe
like your brain where there's something
that it's like to be that matter that
difference is consciousness and it's how
I'm using the word in the movement
although I do actually prefer experience
I think it's slightly less confusing
yeah I've been thinking about that
definition over the last week and I
can't escape this sense that it's still
reductive in the sense that we're
looking at experience through our own
experience right we're defining what
experience means only through the lens
of what it means and feels like to be
human and it doesn't leave a lot of
space or room for for contemplating that
experience could take another form that
we can't relate to well I can see oh no
I think I think but that's so that's
where I'm talking at a more fundamental
so I think and that's partly what I try
to do in the book is strip away
everything that could be human like you
could you could radically change an
experience but the fact of an any
experience at all and you know I get
into these more far-out theories but
even if you contemplate that you know a
single cell or bacteria has some minimal
level of experience that you and I could
never imagine what it would like to what
it would be like if there's any
experience even the most minimal
experience you could imagine if there's
something it's like then that is
consciousness and that could be
completely unlike any human experience
right
it's just whether whether it's
completely dark and dead you know
whether the stars there's there's no
experience there at all it's a
collection of atoms that are doing their
thing but there's nothing that it feels
like at all or or there is in a very
binary way yeah one I yes you know I
mean it's in a binary way once you go
from nothing to something but then of
course
there's this gradation of what's
possible in an experience once you have
experience but yeah I think you can't
you can say that it's either there or
not right the fact that exists begs the
question of the evolutionary advantage
of having it at all
like what is the reason that we
developed this yeah as opposed to you
know the sort of zombie example there
yeah use in the book yeah no and I think
that's that's a that's a very
interesting question and that's kind of
where I swear my thinking started and
it's early on in the book that I posed
these two questions that I think so I
have two categories of intuitions that I
want to challenge one category is our
intuitions about consciousness itself
and then intuitions that occur in other
areas that are in our lives that
strongly influence on or inform our
intuitions about consciousness and so I
kind of put those into two separate
categories and I start with
consciousness and I just thought you
know for myself and in my own notes I
just wanted to get out what are the most
basic strongest intuitions we have about
consciousness and so I asked these two
questions in the book one is is their
behavior we can point to from outside a
system that we can use as conclusive
evidence that consciousness is present
in that system right is there is there
something we can witness from the
outside some physical behavior that we
could say yes any time we see behavior a
B or C that's absolute evidence of
consciousness and I think our intuitive
answer is yes and it's a very strong yes
and even after dissecting this for 15
years my answer is still yes
so an example of that would be I mean
there's so many but uh I often use you
know my daughter if my daughter's fallen
down and she's crying and asking for a
band-aid all of that behavior to me
absolutely signifies that there's
consciousness present right she's having
an experience of pain and and so I
wanted to start there because I thought
this is an important exercise in all
areas of science and this is where our
strongest intuitions are but could we be
wrong
is it possible that the behavior that we
think is evidence of consciousness is
not necessarily evidence of
consciousness and so you can kind of go
in the direction of AI and imagine we
might in the future create something
that seems like a child who is crying
because she fell down but the lights are
actually not on there's no consciousness
there but I think the flip side of that
is also interesting which is even if we
can come up with behaviors and I could
for myself I can't and I think it's
super interesting that we can but on the
other side of that we know that
consciousness can be present with no
behavior at all right so you use the
diving bell and the butterfly yeah have
you read that book I saw yeah yeah so
that's based on a writer who had
something called locked-in syndrome
where I believe his was due to a stroke
but it can it can happen variety of ways
that damaged the brain like a stroke and
it left him completely paralyzed but
with a full experience of consciousness
as full as our experiences right now as
full as his experience was before the
stroke he could hear see think write a
book but he had no way he's completely
paralyzed
except for in his case his left eyelid
there was some mobility left in his left
eyelid and miraculously his caretakers
noticed this and they were able to
develop a way for him to write through
the surra I don't know the exact details
but yeah he lean language made a what
created a certain letter and then he
would spell out words and and wrote this
beautiful book but so that's a case of
even if we can find behavior there's
this other problem in terms of behavior
which is there can be zero behavior and
still be a tremendous the detailed
experience of consciousness the
philosophical zombie example is super
interesting and I think it's related
directly to what we're facing now with
the advent of AI and this uncanny valley
like we see these videos online of
robots doing things that look very human
and it freaks us out but to extrapolate
that example to
it's extreme whether it's a zombie or a
robot that is manifesting human behavior
in all of its forms knows exactly what
to say and how to behave and
demonstrates an outward manifestation of
things like empathy and etc but
technically the lights aren't on the
closer you know it's like this this
asymptotic curve like the closer it
approximates human behavior the question
of consciousness almost in and of itself
seems to fall away like what is the
relevance of consciousness if somebody
is mimic mimicking it to such a precise
agreed yeah is it even a thing is a
consciousness even yeah like you know I
mean it's clearly a thing because it's
actually the only thing we can be sure
exists I mean everything else might
might not be what we think it is we
could we could literally be brains in a
vat or in some computer-generated yeah
alternate right at matrix reality yeah
but the experience you're having is the
experience you're having right like
whatever it is whatever it feels like
that is what consciousness is and so I
think yes so the the thing that's
interesting with with AI is we will have
no way of knowing unless we have a
better understanding of consciousness
ahead of time but then Mike Mike I guess
my question is really like does it
matter then if it's so yeah no I know
what you mean and I think I think we it
Matt it has to matter because it is why
anything matters right like if someone I
mean you can use a lot of examples but
basically everything that matters to us
any any ethical question it has to do
with consciousness if we're talking
about an unconscious system we don't
have any ethical obligations towards
them we're not worried about them we
don't have to think about suffering like
all of suffering happens in
consciousness and so the difference is
everything if if we brought in some
advanced AI that looked like another
human being who just came in
was introduced to us if the if the
scientists who brought this robot in and
said don't worry this robots not
conscious we would have I mean it would
still be hard because our intuition yeah
absolutely
and it's everything that matters in
terms of mattering I mean if this this
being starts to suffer in any way if we
think they're having an experience we
want to help it mm-hmm
it's strange times already well the the
kind of operating definition for
everybody who's walking around without
any kind of more precise familiarity
with this is is is this alignment of
consciousness with identity and a sense
of self right and another one of the
intuitions that you you try to you know
break down a little bit is the
fundamental illusion of self and a
distinction between consciousness and
our I guess lack of selfhood and also
drawing a distinction between
consciousness and complex thought so
yeah so yeah so these kind of fall into
this other category of illusions that
show up in other areas of life but I
think strongly inform our ideas about
what consciousness is and so the self
and conscious will which is not exactly
free will and I can talk a little bit
about distinguishing between the two but
for me the important piece is the idea
the feeling that we have conscious well
and the feeling of being a self a self
being kind of a a self contained
individual entity that I mean our
intuition is actually it's strange when
you say it because you realize there's
something false about the intuition just
in describing it right but what I feel
myself to be even though I've worked
with a lot of neuroscientists I
understand that everything I'm
experiencing is due to all of this
processing in my brain there's some
sense that there is a me that's this
kind of distinct me that is in some way
separate from brain processing that can
they can make these decisions you know
even if my Brent and my brain is you
know pushing me in one direction and you
know telling me I am
I'm should go get a coffee right now
because I'm feeling tired or thirsty or
whatever and then I decide oh you know
now is not the right time to get a
coffee so there's there somehow there's
the sense that I there's the me that can
choose to follow my instincts or not and
that is the thing that is making all of
the choices and so it the the self and
conscious will are really part of the
same illusion and it's the sense that
there's a separate self that has this
will and so there's a lot of
neuroscience now disprove I mean showing
that these are that these are truly
illusions and you can and many people
have had the experience of breaking
through these illusions in meditation
through use of psychedelics and we now
know actually the the kind of network in
the brain called the default mode
network is responsible for creating this
this sense of self and so when that is
quieted through meditation or
psychedelics or by other means people
talk about having the same kind of
experience of realizing that that way
they usually experience themselves is is
a kind of illusion right that
consciousness exists outside of the self
our senses are elusive re are loose or a
sense of yeah yeah well and then and
then also just in terms of how the brain
processes things and how many things are
happening before it rises to the level
of our awareness so that often if not
always I mean there's a lot of research
suggesting that this is basically always
the case that every time we feel like
we've made this free decision you know
we're contemplating two different
choices and we decide to go with option
a that that has already taken place in
terms of processing before we are aware
of it and there are other systems that
are that we know much more about
actually that are just like this
and binding is one of them that I talked
about in the book yeah so binding
the way for people to really grok what
this is all about in the sense that we
receive these inputs from the outside
world at differing speeds like you see
something before we hear it there is
this delay mechanism wherein
our brain assembles all of these inputs
in some kind of Final Cut Pro program
and then presents it to us in a cohesive
whole but that's not the way yeah that's
not the way it actually happens and that
the the kind of behavioral reactions
that that we manifest in in in response
to those occur prior to our conscious
awareness of having done so mmhmm yeah
yeah you can I mean I can see you know I
mean it's also realizing that our
experience of will our conscious will
isn't what it feels like either can be a
bummer but I thought there's another way
to look at me we want to believe that
we're sentient beings that are in
control of our lab no it's actually and
truly we are not it's a very
controversial point actually because
people get very emotional about it and I
thought long and hard before I included
it in the book actually dismantling
conscious will well your husband is
written extensively about this idea yeah
so it's not it's not new to anyone who's
coming to you via him that's true yeah
yeah but still yeah I had I had this guy
dr. Judd Breuer in here two days ago and
he's done once he's done a lot of work
on the default mode Network okay doing
fMRI is on people's brains after
mindfulness and meditation practices and
we talked a lot about a little bit but
more he's more in the mindfulness space
and it was super interesting to see that
relationship of you know sort of toning
down or turning off the default mode
Network and the dissolution of our our
sense of identity or self allowing pure
consciousness to enter and kind of the
impact of that experience yeah so yeah I
actually be curious to know how how many
people experience that is positive
versus negative but there's definitely
there's a positive way to experience
that and it can be extremely positive
right it's part of the reason why
there's been so much success with this
psychedelic research on PTSD that it
part part of the healing is actually
realizing that the sense of a separate
self is an illusion and there's kind of
a connectedness with everyone and
everything that comes about when when
you're quiet that default mode network
yeah I think the the experience if
you've had it is universally positive
because it provides a sense of connected
connectivity to the world but I think
intellectually it's it's it's hard to
grab and very hard to grapple with yeah
yeah yeah no it's it's completely
counter to it and I think that's part of
the reason why this process is probably
going to take a long time like the
process even just of the neuroscience we
now have and know to be true it's taking
forever even for some of the
neuroscientists who are doing the work
to really be able to accept the
implications because it is just deeply
it's not the way we're wired to think
about things it's not really wired to
experience things but again it's the
reason why I think it's such an
important thing to be doing right now
with consciousness because I think it is
the only path to deeper understanding
and to better understanding right yeah
we have this idea that our consciousness
there's a locus for our consciousness
and it resides in our head behind our
eyes yeah and that's fundamentally you
know the makeup of who we are and a way
of looking at that or defying our
intuition about that is - you taught
you've talked a lot about this on other
shows but but on a neuroscience level
understanding that neuroscientists have
not been able to find that look it's not
like oh it's it resides right here in
this part of the brain we see it flaring
up when you activate it and also this
practice of from that book about the you
know pretending
don't have a head or like what it's like
to not having know that yeah having no
head yeah to understand that is nice
can't be can't be located in any
geographical precise location yeah I
think that consciousness can in some
sense the self can't I mean there there
is no self no I'm confused
so the so there are different ways of
looking at it and as I say in my book
that I'm kind of 50/50 on this at this
point but we we basically assume that
consciousness is created by at the very
least a brain and a central nervous
system so we can kind of look at it from
that perspective there are all these
other theories that I carefully talk
about in my book which I completely
rejected myself for many years and
didn't even think they were they merited
my hands like I'm talking about if we're
gonna get to that trust me we've already
gotten to it so I need to get a little
disclaimer before for its we start
really talking about it but Pan psychism
is this category of theories that posits
that fund that consciousness could be a
fundamental feature of the universe down
to the level of atoms even possibly
originating out of some sort of field
the the fluctuations of which give
matter this intrinsic property of
experience so that they're all these
physical properties of matter and then
there's actually an intrinsic property
of all matter so that there's some level
of experience wherever there is matter
present so you can kind of answer this
question of where consciousness is in
space-time from either angle from from
if we just assume consciousness exists
only in brains we know that that is I
mean there's no like pinpoint location
right but the brain itself is creating a
certain experience that it does not
exist in your chalkboard right your your
your chalkboard is not participating in
the experience is my brain and so it's
oh so there's some sense in which you
can talk about a physical location in a
brain-based view of consciousness but
even if you go down some pens psychic
rabbit hole it's still for at least for
the the theories that make sense to me
the way that I there are theories that
don't make sense to me within pen
psychics I mean I definitely when I
consider those views and so so as I was
saying I rejected it categorically for a
long time it just sounded completely
crazy to me and went against everything
that I understood about the brain and
the more I fixated on the subject and
the more I read in the more I thought
about it the more open I actually become
my own thoughts actually started leading
me there like what what if and then I
realized there was this category of
theories called pen psychism and so then
I started doing research there and there
are actually many mainstream
well-respected scientists who take some
view either within pen psychism or some
you know it's basically a pan psychic
view whether or not they they considered
they call it that by by the name which
I've said many times the terrible name
we need a new name
but it's so taboo for scientists to
consider something like this and if you
have actually done it publicly which i
think is incredible most of them there
are many more of them than I realized
because they won't admit it publicly
because it's such a career ender so I do
truly believe it's a legitimate category
of theories that we should be open to
and now I forgot your class I was
answering some other we're talking
physical location of Christ so within
Penn psychism still each area of matter
would entail whatever experience make
sense for that area of matter even it
underpin psycho so I think there's some
there's a sense in which consciousness
no matter how you look at it is tied to
matter right that that consciousness can
be redefined
and perhaps it's not exactly what we
think it is and it's a fundamental
aspect of all matter going down to you
know the atom all the way up to the
human being and beyond and I have to say
that that like that activates my you
know new-age proclivities you know it's
like I want to believe that that's true
so badly beyond the beyond part yeah I
just I just think it's cool you know
it's like wow think about that like
wouldn't that be amazing that everything
we thought about consciousness
you know it's so much more complicated
and vast to be an essential property of
what yeah the universe is comprised of
yeah is an amazing idea and it's it's I
guess it's a reality but it's sort of
disheartening that there are certain
ideas out there that would be career
Enders for scientist just to talk about
and think about because science is about
like science at the cutting edge has to
be about asking questions that no one's
willing to ask and exploring them as
open-mindedly as possible yes I agree
and I think I think it's kind of the
right time to start making noises about
this because you know there are a
variety of reasons but I can see why
it's gotten such a bad rap and I can see
the ways in which science gets
threatened and also the ways in which
certain theories get co-opted by some
ridiculous you know pseudo scientific
New Age idea and then those scientists
kind of get implicated in the pseudos
you know careful yeah I get it but it is
it's it's a legitimate category of
theories and it's incredibly interesting
and given that we've made no progress on
what's what's called the hard problem of
consciousness the fact that it's still
so deeply mysterious and that it doesn't
seem that more understanding of brain
processes will give us more information
about this fundamental nature of
consciousness what it what it actually
is this is I mean this is where I
started is this is why these are the
moments in science where we have to
start challenging intuitions and be open
to me
we've been thinking about it all wrong
the the kind of way in here seems to me
to be by challenging this emergence you
know the emergent phenomenon of
consciousness this idea that yes we
understand as human beings that we are
conscious and that perhaps animals are
but as you slide down the scale at what
point is something that is technically
alive that is cellular not conscious and
you know from a binary perspective is it
a switch that gets flicked at what point
does the fetus become conscious yeah
there has to be some demarcation line
right and the more you know that you
realize like this it's a gradation kind
of thing but is there a you know just
semi consciousness become consciousness
and then if so what is
semi-consciousness it all falls it falls
part yeah no I mean in some sense it
kind of has to be binary there's if
there's a spectrum either the all of
reality is is the spectrum or you drop
off the spectrum at the end of the
spectrum right at that point it's it's
binary right so yes and that is that's
just this eternal mystery that we don't
seem anywhere close to the ad it's all
and so I do think kind of flipping the
question is is it is incredibly
interesting especially since so much of
the science is actually very intuition
challenging already and we can kind of
start there and just see I mean my book
is all about asking questions I think
it's interesting even if you know what
works what we're asking is is wrong and
there's a clear and what we what our
intuitions are telling us is right
there's no reason not to say let's just
totally break this open yeah yeah so if
you were to define consciousness at you
know at the molecular level like well
that definition be I think the
definition is always the same even
though it's hard to have a definition
but I think it's always the same as long
as you're talking about consciousness in
its most fundamental sense so experience
is the best word I can come up with but
if there is any experience at all if
there's something that it's like to be
that matter to be that collection
Adams's then there is consciousness
present there if it's completely dead
and lights are out and there's
absolutely no experience being had then
it's it's not but you need a very broad
definition of experience experience not
in the sense of what we would qualify as
experience maybe although I'm but so
this is the problem with a lot of these
words I think experience is the cleanest
word I think awareness brings in other
things that aren't necessarily conscious
experience we usually think of it as
something more complex because more
complex creep creatures having a very
complex complex experience and so it's
kind of the problem with all talking
about consciousness in general is we are
these incredibly complex systems the
brain is the most complex thing we know
of in the universe right and that and
our experience is of being that so we
assume that consciousness is complex
because we associate it with our own
experience and don't know how or if we
can apply it to other things but I think
there are ways that we can imagine their
little thought experiments and theirs in
the beginning of one of my chapters one
of the chapters in my book I do a little
bit of it like a guided visualization to
try to get someone to imagine even you
know from the perspective of a baby I
don't use a baby in this sense but at
least that brings it to the to the human
level what experience is like when you
start stripping away all of our inputs
like we're without sight without hearing
without you know if you're just talking
about super minimal I think there's some
way in which we can imagine you know a
worm say which many people think worms
aren't conscious but you can imagine
there's something that it's like to be a
worm there's some level of consciousness
there it would be so incredibly minimal
right like whatever the feeling is it
would be probably not even in the sense
of a localized self it might be like
pressure or heat or and so I think we
can imagine experience being very very
minimal and my guess is that if it does
go as far down as worms or even deeper
it
gets more and more minimal right along
those lines I want to talk about the the
consciousness in the plant kingdom oh
yes there's some super interesting so
especially like the Douglas fir yes
Apple that you use right so I didn't
know a lot of this before I wrote my
book I did all of this research
most of the research for the book and
what's interesting is I brought in plant
behavior kind of to prove the opposite
point I didn't bring plant and plant
behavior because I think plants are
conscious although this point kind of
makes you question whether they are but
I brought it in because I was addressing
this issue of are there behaviors we can
point to that that are evidence absolute
evidence of consciousness and there are
so many plant behaviors that are so much
more similar than I realized
and I think then most people realize
down to the mechanism so it's it's kind
of like behavior that you would describe
in similar terms to the way we describe
human behavior but they're also similar
genes similar processes of cell changes
resulting in electrical signals in much
the same way that our that our brains do
and of course they're very different but
they're similar enough that I use it
because we assume plants are not
conscious and so you can kind of play
this trick on yourself by saying okay if
plants do these things that when humans
do them we say that that's evidence of
consciousness but we assume plants are
not conscious they're doing all of this
without consciousness why maybe we don't
need consciousness for these behaviors
in humans and this is just part of the
intuition challenging that I was doing
but yeah so you you spoke about the the
tree behavior the Douglas fir and the
birch this is the work of Susan Simard I
don't know if you've seen her TED talk
so worth watching she did work in the
Canadian National Forest and and I
actually think she grew some of her own
trees in her own like lab setting to
study the communications that happen
under
and what are called mycorrhizal networks
these are fungal networks under the
ground
so there are root systems but there are
also systems of fungus that help trees
communicate to each other share carbon
with each other they share defense
signals there is this incredibly
elaborate system of communication
happening underground some of which and
I use this in my book because it mimics
human behavior to some extent where the
trees that have dropped seedlings she
refers to them as the mother trees are
able to recognize through these networks
which trees that have grown in the
forest are their own kin and they send
them more carbon and they send them
defense signals that they're not sending
to other trees and there's a sense in
which they're protecting they are
protecting their kids it's unbelievable
they make more room for their roots and
you can see how this could all happen
without consciousness right like it's
all trippy but you could still say okay
that's so interesting all that that
happens there's all this communication
and cells talking to each other and and
that could all just be happening in the
dark right that could be happening in
the same way that we imagine our
computer processing systems are
happening in the dark and if that's true
why do we think all of these things that
we're doing require consciousness and so
I think that's an interesting starting
point but it does also make you wonder
if trees are cut I mean what comes up
for me when I think about that is is the
beautiful symbiosis of these ecologies
right like we're caught up in our sense
of self were we separate ourselves from
others I mean you talk about Stardust
and yeah we yeah we're all Stardust but
when you really think about that we
don't yeah and when you think about the
limitations of free will and the fact
that we're just truly reacting to our
environments and there is no you know
impermeable barrier between ourselves in
the world and the Sun and all of these
things that were reacting constantly to
our environment and that we are very
much in that same place of responding to
our environment
adapting yeah trees and forests and you
know all of these sorts of things are
instructive because they show us that
that integral the integration is so
undeniable when you drill down on it
yeah I know so so I've been using plants
more recently I've been getting into
more hairy discussions about free will
and you can use plant behavior to talk
about this as well because you wouldn't
you don't think the plants are making
this decision like ok no no I'm going to
give more carbon to you over there and
they are as you said there's this
complex way in which they are connected
and responding and we don't in plant
behavior we don't mistake that response
however complex and interesting it is
for free will right and I think you can
you can map that on to human beings as
well that there's a sense in which it's
all a system from the brain to our
bodies to the air we're breathing two of
the sound waves that I'm speaking that
are bouncing off you I mean there
there's this connection that we don't
see but that is is there not only do we
not see it where our brains are rigged
to convince is that right it's something
very different yeah yeah I don't know
what to do with that though I know I can
tell you this as somebody who's who's
been vegan like plant-based for a very
long time like in the Twitterverse like
the plant consciousness argument comes
up a lot yeah I actually just heard
someone for the first time use it for
the reverse argument which I'd never
heard before which was they they're so
complex and they seem like that you know
the sense that they he'd spent it was um
it was this a podcast that you did I
listen to it he's the guy who went to
the Amazon yes and he was immersed in
that biosphere yeah such a Corey Allen
yes but there were some sense of like
I'm how am i how is this type of
consciousness any more important than
that type of contrast and I don't follow
that path and I think there are reasons
to think that
suffering there's there's definitely a
range of suffering and even if plants
are our conscious and I mean even if
everything's conscious I think yeah
definitely make a good argument for some
things being able to suffer a lot more
than other things well what was
interesting about that is that he said
he was a longtime vegetarian and then he
had that experience in the Amazonian
rainforest and then he began eating meat
after that because he saw himself as
just part of this greater whole but I
couldn't help but thinking yeah but
eating all those animals is actually
contributing to the destruction of this
thing that you fell in love with I don't
know yeah yeah to see it right
differently for sure but it does I think
all of that shaking up our intuition
specifically about self and free will
and and just about consciousness in
general get us to see things very
differently and I think I mean for me it
brings me a lot of joy and it was really
the first reason I decided to turn my
notes into something that I was writing
for the public was really just to share
this feeling of awe that I get in
contemplating all of this and I think it
can it can do that I think it can be
kind of a spiritual a source of a
spiritual experience and it's another
word we can use about a hundred
different ways but yeah for me as
someone who's not religious and I feel
like I'm a fairly spiritual person a lot
of it comes from from contemplating
things like this how does that work with
your famous atheist husband I think he's
a very spiritual person
I don't I think he's the word if he is I
really did yeah I mean we neither of us
like the word for obvious reasons but he
actually used it I'm forgetting now
which book I should know but he used it
in one of his books and he gives oh and
waking up he uses the word spiritual and
he talks about why he thinks it's a
necessary word and it shouldn't mean all
the things that that people have used it
for and there's actually a new sorry
it's not that new but Thomas Metzinger
is a philosopher who's wonderful and he
it's something about spirituality I
don't know how long ago but not not that
long ago I actually posted an excerpt of
it on my website because it's so
beautiful and brilliant and is is a kind
of an argument for taking the word back
to mean something very different from
what it generally means in pop culture
now his his essay is called spirituality
and intellectual honesty or maybe the
other way around intellectual honesty
and spirituality but he equates
spirituality with a kind of a scientific
mindset of seeking truth and yeah so I
so his his article has made me think a
lot about spirituality and what I mean
by spirituality when I say it and I
absolutely thought I think of myself
that way I absolutely think of Sam that
way and yeah for me it's more of a kind
of staring into the unknown while
seeking truth and feeling this intimate
connection to the rest of the universe
and so you know that can be done through
meditation I mean it can be done in a
variety of ways but I mean I I think
well first of all you know a guy who
stops out of college because he has an
experience and goes on a 10-year journey
that takes him to ashrams and all these
met I mean this guy's a seeker you know
you can call it spiritual or whatever
but he's on a journey for greater deeper
understanding yeah and I don't see
science and spirituality is incompatible
at all in fact your book is testament to
that the more you drill down on these
crazy ideas the more room you provide
for oh and wonder it just how mysterious
and amazing all of this is yeah that's
what I think that's why ya know that's
why I call it hesitantly call it a
source of spirituality for me yeah so
another intuition that that you confront
and and debunk about consciousness or
what we think about when we think about
ourselves has to do with you you explore
it through like the split brain
experiments and Toxoplasma that allows
you to realize like that Hey
we're not we're not so much in control
or that consciousness isn't exactly this
unified entity yeah so yeah this is some
of the research I use to help help
people break through or see the sense of
self and conscious will as illusions so
the split brain research I think does
this incredibly well and this joint
explained yeah so this this is research
that was first done by the
neuroscientist Michael Gazzaniga and
Roger Sperry and they were doing
research on patients who had a surgery
to essentially split the brain in two
this sounds like a horrific procedure
but it actually helped a lot of people
with epilepsy because an epileptic
seizure is essentially an electrical
storm that can spread the most
devastating most dangerous ones spread
throughout the brain and so they they
discovered that if they they cut the
brain through the corpus callosum and
essentially split it into into its
separate halves it would prevent the
electrical storm from from spreading to
the entire brain and many patients got
incredible relief from this and for the
most part you couldn't tell they seemed
normal and healthy after the fact
through this research they discovered
that there was a sense in which the
person the split the two split sides of
the brain were kind of like separate
people in terms of their consciousness
and in terms of their their will as well
and so I do want me to describe some of
the experiments go supersonic yeah it's
super interesting I never tire of
thinking about this and what it must be
like but essentially the patients end up
like conjoined twins almost where
they're they have like separate minds
but they're sharing this body so one of
the the the famous experiments is of a
split brain patient so the way the brain
works is our visual field the right side
of the visual field gets projected on
to the left hemisphere the left visual
field is projected onto the right
hemisphere the same is true for a lot of
things like our hands the the sense
perceptions from our hands go to the
opposite hemisphere and so they were
able to kind of separately question and
communicate with each side of the brain
so they would flash a word I think in my
book I use the one where they flash the
word key and they flashed that to the
left visual field which would only go to
the right side of the brain because
that's where it goes and normally that
would be shared across the corpus
callosum but this has been split so it's
stay it's it only gets received by the
right hemisphere so the right hemisphere
has seen the word key the left
hemisphere hasn't seen anything and when
you ask the person also the the speaking
centre of the brain language
communication is not always but most
fear in this patient it was in the left
hemisphere so the experimenter asks the
person what word did you just see and
they say I didn't see anything and
that's because the speaking part of the
brain is is the left hemisphere then
they'll say there'll be a bunch of
objects on the table in rocks and coins
and and things for them to choose from
then they'll say reach out and pick up
the object of the word you just saw and
the person with their left hand because
it's controlled by their right
hemisphere who saw the word key will
reach out and pick up a key and this is
just replicated over and over again with
the same results so in there there are
different ways that they that they can
ask various questions there was a child
I'm forgetting the name they used her
and I think they kept his name anonymous
but they used a name what he was famous
for having the ability actually to speak
with both hemispheres and so they were
able to get a lot of information from
him but they would ask him questions and
he would have different answers
depending on which hemisphere they they
projected the question to so it's crazy
he wanted to be true to you know one
side wanted to be I forget now but you
know one side wanted to be a draftsman
when he grew up and the other side
wanted to be something else and
they're bizarre cases of someone one
half of their brain being an atheist and
the other one being a Christian the
whole the whole range is possible but it
really is like you end up with conjoined
twins rather than a single unifying and
so what do you make of this like how
does this inform yeah you think about
consciousness so they're they're a
couple of ways and actually the
interpreter is something that comes up
here that I that I didn't mention which
is super interesting which is the the
language side of the brain it was
Michael Gazzaniga and another scientist
kind of came up with this term the
interpreter for this experience that
they noticed or phenomenon they noticed
again and again in these patients where
they would give a command to the to the
patient to get up and walk to the end of
the room and so the patient would do
this sorry I always I know the example
years so it's like so it's to the right
hem they tell the right hemisphere get
up and walk and they'll get up and serve
walk to the back of the room then they
ask the person so the speaking left
hemisphere is going to answer why why
did you just get up and the left
hemisphere is not aware of that command
so the left hemisphere doesn't actually
have information about why his body got
up and started walking and in most cases
it will come up with an instantaneous
response that kind of makes sense that
it doesn't seem that it's alive doesn't
seem like the person fabricated this
it's a function of the brain it's kind
of have an answer and he'll say oh I got
thirsty I was good I was standing up to
get a glass of water and this is a
little bit of an insight into into
conscious will the idea that and many
neuroscientists think there's something
like this there's a kind of an
interpreter effect happening all the
time or a lot of the time where we have
this unconscious brain processing and
kind of rises to the level of
consciousness and we think we know the
reason
and we may not be right about that right
we're sort of post-hoc coming up with
rationalizations for behaviors that are
already underway yeah right using
example also if you being startled from
a noise in the middle of the night
before you were like your body moved
before you heard yeah the thing yeah
yeah and that was more kind of an
interruption of the binding process or I
think and there are these disorders that
interrupt a binding so that people don't
actually experience the sights and the
sounds of things in the same moment
happening at the same moment how does
that manifest in an individual like if
they're not binding properly it's just
mishmash of everything coming in at
different times yeah yeah there's a
category of disorders called agnosia
which is the inability of the brain to
process sensory information together so
there's a whole right I mean there's
strange things that can happen that I
just discovered there's something called
finger agnosia which is the inability to
differentiate between your different
fingers but basically everything we
experience is the brain is doing all of
this for us right it like once you start
to pull these things apart in the split
brain research does the same thing it's
like everything that we kind of take for
granted and think this is the way things
are you manipulate the brain a little
bit and you realize it just breaks down
yeah like if there if you split
somebody's brain and you know one side's
an atheist and one side is a Christian
what does that say about how we think
about who we are what is the self right
yeah or is there no such thing right you
know yeah that gets back to the bummer
part I guess I always I always see two
paths they're like there's a fork in the
road you can go the bummer path but you
can also go of the kind of like
surrendering to this bizarre universe
we're in and just letting it be
something different than you thought it
was yeah I mean at all I feel like
whatever we discover it's all kind of
magical I noticed I'm sure you notice
this having kids they ask you to explain
everything and they don't understand
anything and you realize every answer is
crazy
right
you just might not answer any about her
like I am I saying
blue and when we breathe are we
breathing the sky and I'm you know she's
just trying to understand yeah
extending the micro Raizel example is
this Toxoplasma great example that you
use which just also further you know
enhances the mystery of all of this when
you realize like that your your
neurology can be hijacked by these you
know microscopic entities that then take
over and control your behavior yeah
although the parasite research is so
interesting and I knew a little bit
about it before I started writing the
book as a book but I did a lot more
reading and it just gets creepier and
creepier
but parasites control the behavior of
their hosts and they do it with neuro
chemicals because or not not always but
but often they're either mimicking the
neuro chemicals of the creature its
invading or they're just disrupting some
system so that they get the creature to
do what it needs it to do for its own
needs so yeah Toxoplasma that that's an
interesting one that's one a lot of
people know about in cats where it needs
to reproduce in the intestines of a cat
and so in order to but then it it it
part of its life cycle happens outside
of the cat but it needs to eventually
make its way back to a cat and so you
know rats who are that are infected with
this parasite who have normally have a
natural fear of cats this parasite
alters their brain chemistry in such a
way that they actually become less
fearful in general but they are less
fearful of cats they can be drawn to
cats they're drawn to the smell of cat
urine like they suddenly become they
just run headlong into the cat deucey in
some cases yeah and that's just this
parasite needing to get back but my
point about all of that is there's some
sense in which we're already in that
circumstance right like we are
our conscious experience is really at
the mercy of whatever processing we are
a part of there's some interesting
science happening right now in the
microbiome where they're discovering
this nexus between the quality of your
gut flora and the foods that you crave
yeah and that again you think like well
my body's telling me I need this it's
like no actually this thing inside of
you that's what it feeds on well in your
body is hardly your body and I forget
the numbers but it's so no it's like
this percentage right yeah yeah yeah all
right well the ultimate kind of wrench
in this whole thing that just takes it
off a cliff is time mmm so let's talk
about time okay I probably I feel like
I'm not qualified to talk about time
although I will say I keep recommending
his book because I think it's so
beautifully done Carl over Valley's new
book on time called the order of time I
think one of the reasons I love it but
it's just it's it's a great book on an
accessible way to kind of understand
where the science is at at this point
but he does this he ends the book on
consciousness and he kind of talks about
how the two are interrelated and I love
that because I end my book on time and
there is some sense in which you know
whether at the level of physics they're
interrelated you know we don't know but
our conscious experience certainly
couldn't exist without time there's
something it is it's in many ways all
about time so explain okay how does that
work so I think I think many people have
this experience in meditation and a lot
of the kids that I teach get have
communicate this experience quite often
that it starts to make them wonder what
the present moment is so we have so our
experience is just forever in what we
feel is the present moment right it's
this experience of what's now one when
you start to pay closer and closer
attention to that it's hard to even
understand what we mean by now and in
what sense
time is moving and it's interesting that
we use the word moving it's like we talk
about time in spatial sense and yeah so
I think I think it's interesting even
just you know how am I to talk about
this in the last chapter how much time
do we need for a conscious moment right
and this may be different for humans
than for other animals is a common
flickering intervals or is it a
continuum right and it gets into you
then explore this this these two kind of
countervailing theories of present ISM
versus eternalism and how we think about
time yes yeah
and I think I could be wrong but I think
Karl or Valley actually says neither of
them are right although he basically
says there is no such thing as time as
we experience it and we we think of it
to be that it just it it completely
falls apart there's no present moment in
the universe that is consistent
throughout the universe right there's
things at the quantum level there's no
past and present even like things go in
both directions and you can't tell one
from the other what was your question
using myself so we consciously we
experience time in you know in a present
ISM context like a flowing yeah you know
in Raritan er way right but the science
suggests that it's really it probably is
more of an eternal ism kind of thing
that all of these things are happening
simultaneously in multi-dimensions and
yet we can't even really fully yes yeah
well and I think whether or not
eternalism is the right way to describe
it like the block universe I think is a
controversial concept the idea that it's
it's a static thing that every point in
time exists always but present ism
doesn't seem accurate either I mean it's
clear it's clearly not accurate but it's
interesting that that's the way we
experience the world and there's there's
something about our experience that kind
of lights up these different and we call
them moments
and we're only experiencing them one at
a time mm-hmm so why explore time now
like what is the relationship between
how we're trying to understand time and
how we are trying to think about
consciousness I mean for me the reason I
brought it up in the book mostly is just
because I think it's incredibly
interesting that our experience of the
present moment is something we can't
even quite mm-hmm get our minds around
our own experience of what it is
actually Donald Hofmann is doing this
work I don't know if you're aware of him
he's very interesting he has a book
coming out in August called the case
against reality and he is a very he's
doing this very with this very rigorous
science and I think some peace some
scientists are questioning what he's
doing but I think it's very interesting
and he's certainly grounded in science
but he's his question is should we are
we thinking about it backwards
so is it is it so hard to understand
consciousness because we're thinking
we're living in this non conscious
universe that somehow gives rise to
consciousness that that's not the right
way to think about it is it possible
that consciousness is fundamental and
gives rise to the physical world and so
you know even he will say I might be
wrong but we should explore this yeah
that's and so those are the play the
types of places that these intersections
happen between the mysteries were coming
up against in quantum mechanics and
right in your research your research for
doing the book what what really out
there ideas did you come across that
didn't make the cut yeah I mean like you
went out on a limb to include you know
this para para psychism because I'm
sorry parasite know it even worse and I
know in in your podcast with Sam he's
like you know he's saying like he was
trying to talk you out of this but yeah
I would imagine you came across some
other stuff too you're like yeah I mean
I get you out there yeah I think there
are some
my feeling is that some people have
taken what I think are legitimate
questions within pants psychism to make
all kinds of claims like the universe is
common there's something called the
combination problem in pants psychism
which I talked a little bit about in the
book because actually don't see it as a
problem I think it's partly because
we're confused about being selves and
that illusion that's misleading us there
but within this the the combination
problem is essentially the philosophical
problem if pants psychism is true how is
it that these smaller points of
consciousness in the atoms of my body in
the cells come together to create this
other form of consciousness and I
actually I don't think about it that way
when I contemplate pen psychism that's
not the way I think about it
but so then the natural next question is
is there some kind of human you know
larger human consciousness or
consciousness of the universe that there
was an article recently I think titled
is the universe conscious so I think
again confusing consciousness with
complex thoughts right I think it's it's
a really a misunderstanding
of the implications of pan psyche ISM
that lead people to what look to me like
slightly religious beliefs that for many
people give them some gets them out of
the feeling that they're they're bummed
we're coming across and they want to
prove that yeah it's not comforting to
me it's annoying but I get I get why it
would be comforting but ya know the idea
that there's some there's some plan
there's some path there's this higher
consciousness we don't you know we can
let go of God but now we're gonna use
this other thing as a placement for for
God but the idea that human brains that
aren't connected would have some bigger
mind that it I mean it's you know those
are the type of plan for every single
person yeah right but that aside it's
undeniable that there is an organizing
principle on some level going on here
that I don't know that we'll ever fully
be able to comprehend yeah but yeah is
is certainly true nonetheless right yeah
what that is whatever it's true is true
well you're somebody who who has been a
meditator for a long time and I know
your your entry point to that started
with migraines right which is something
my wife mmm deals with and has dealt
with she was just just recently in the
last two days like down and out just
tried everything it's been a real
challenge for her but that's originally
if I'm not mistaken what kind of brought
you into that world yes so I when when I
was yeah I was about eight years old
when I first started getting migraines
and there was a moment at which I was in
a particularly having experiencing a
particularly bad one where I'm sure this
happens to your wife - it's it's the
strangest thing or you're in so much
pain and it's actually a migraine is
kind of hard to even pinpoint where the
pain is but any tiny little movement
like just taking a big breath or
adjusting myself would be like was
crashed in my head and so I had to stay
incredibly still and I guess because I
was so focused on like all these little
micro movements and just you know I
think when you're in that much pain and
I know other people have had this
experience just the slightest adjustment
in one way or the other can can make a
huge difference so you can bring you a
just a little bit of relief it feels
like a lot and that's in that
circumstance in the same way that the
movement that makes it makes it more
painful does so it was aware of that and
I think as I was staying really still I
was able to notice that just the
psychological state I was in that I had
gotten myself into or maybe that's not a
fair way to describe it but I realized
that I was kind of like fighting the
pain it's hard to describe but with my
psychological stance right like my my
way of my way of kind of looking at the
pain or being with the pain was with a
lot of resistance and like wanting it to
go away
that's not the right way to describe
wasn't with words it was a mess yeah I
mean almost felt like a movement right
and so I just decided in that moment I
don't know why but I just decided to
stop doing that and to just get curious
about what I was experiencing and to
kind of get closer to that just really
let it be there and really kind of
almost like facing your fear like let's
just get into this like what what is
this and I that was kind of the first
moment for me of noticing that curiosity
could be helpful and can it be an
antidote to different types of pain
which is I think part of a realization
that comes through meditation also but
more specifically just not resisting
something and kind of having a stance of
being curious and letting things be even
when you're in terrible pain it creates
just that you know the slightest bit of
relief and that was a powerful insight
for me that I then when I was able to or
when it occurred to me I was able to
apply to other areas of my life not just
physical pain but psychological pain to
to just getting curious about what is
this thing that I'm resisting made it a
little more tolerable yeah that's
interesting that's that's something
something that Jed brewer was talking
about the other day here like using like
his his work is really in cravings and
addiction and using mindfulness it's a
kind of pain and the idea of like like
letting go of your you know willful
impulse to try to combat this and
releasing your self judgments and all
the emotions that swirl around it yeah
and just being curious like being
present with it curious about what it is
and when you approach it from that
perspective it's it almost like it it's
like it dissolves the solid mm-hmm yeah
yeah no I think that it's I hadn't
thought about it in that context but it
must be a great tool because it kind of
it gets you to see thoughts and even
sensations like pain as almost as energy
right
it's this thing that is pretty amorphous
that when you look at it very closely
and craving is a really interesting one
and I actually had it's not quite
craving but it's in my meditation
practice the thing when I if I'm sitting
along retreat the thing that I now that
I now welcome because I think it's so
interesting is the desire to move right
like what it's very hard to pinpoint
what that feeling is like a you know I
know a touch to the hand I can kind of
know what that feeling is pretty clearly
but wanting to move is very hard to find
in it's not localized in any particular
yeah so any kind of like craving or
wanting when you take a closer look at
it I think becomes a kind of you realize
it's a kind of energy for it if it
starts to break down yeah yeah talk to
me about the work that you do with kids
and meditation so yeah so I've been
teaching meditation to children for
close to 15 years I think I've stopped
counting but I think it's about 15 years
ever since I discovered Susan Kaiser
Greenland's work which I think is truly
brilliant and unlike any of the other
work that has been done with children
although there's a lot of great stuff
out there now
she created a secular program for
children in schools based on the bop
asana teachings but truly turned it into
a completely secular program and I had
just finished a meditation retreat where
I kept thinking about how beneficial it
would have been to for me to learn to
meditate as a child and how I was kind
of naturally inclined as I think a lot
of I noticed this in my classes so I
think it's like any other ability or
talent where most people can learn it
but some people are like truly gifted at
it and can learn it much more easily and
I think actually in general I think
children can learn to meditate more
easily than adults but then there are
the ones who really take to it pretty
quickly and just
fall into it right away and then they
can get derive all of this benefit from
it when they're young so I came out of
that retreat mostly wondering why we
don't teach this to children and
thinking about it in the context of
physical education that you know like we
consider this to be mandatory like we
have to keep our bodies healthy and this
is such an incredibly powerful tool for
keeping our minds healthy and why this
right how's everybody accumulates all
sorts of baggage I can barely learn and
it's completely closed off yeah that
openness the open mindedness of children
seems to be you know perfectly suited
because they're not like they want to be
in that place of all annoyance right and
they still there in that place all the
time it's like my daughter asking if
she's breathing the sky and like why her
breath isn't blue and you know it's all
mysterious and and there's no idea that
it should be one way versus another way
and so much of that is an obstacle to
learning how to meditate when you don't
know what a self is or what freewill is
or know what you know you're just very
open to the next experience how many of
the kids that you teach end up adopting
like a consistent practice I wish I knew
that's at work it's all over the place
I'm sure I I've heard from many parents
I get these wonderful emails and
sometimes photo actually got this text a
couple of years ago from a mom who said
we couldn't find I won't I'll use a
different name Rebecca we couldn't find
Rebecca we were visiting my parents we
couldn't find Rebecca we were looking
all over the place and then I found her
and she showed me the picture and she's
sitting meditating under a tree in the
backyard it's amazing yeah it's amazing
and it's the most wonderful thing about
it is that what I was hoping was true is
true that she clearly was deriving so
much benefit from it she could she was
this is something she wanted to do on
her own she just decided to go do it in
a moment that she felt like she wanted
to or needed to or whatever
does it work with your own kids much
harder tell me about it yeah yeah I keep
thinking I need someone else to record
all of my guided meditations for my kids
yeah yeah yeah I mean so I all of my
meditations and lessons are now on the
waking up app and I have a long page and
it's maybe slightly intimidating because
there's so much text but I put
everything in there that I think is
actually really important to know before
you teach kids how to meditate and I
forget oh so and and one of the points I
make there is that it's really important
to not force kids to not really to not
put pressure on them at all to do it or
to learn it and that I think the best
thing that parents can do is model it
for their children which is true of so
many things and my kids especially my
older daughter she's 10
it's definitely interested and I got
very lucky actually they invited me to
teach a meditation class at her
elementary school so I taught her class
kindergarten first for three years
through second grade and you know that's
not advice I can give to parents you
know it just kind of stops there but
what's interesting is I think children
really learn meditation better in the
context of a group or a school or like a
learning setting and I think at home you
really just have to offer it and talk to
them about it so they know it's
something that's available and show them
how it helps you and I actually think
it's important to do it in front of them
I think they become interested without
telling them they have to do it just
actually sit down and set a timer and
that parents I know who meditate who
have kids who meditate that that isn't
Orange yeah I mean it's it's like any
good behavior that you want to instill
in your kid if you create restrictions
and mandatory rules around it it's
that's a recipe for a disaster yeah I
mean it can go both ways but meditation
is definitely that way because it's
totally an internal
so you can't you know you can tell them
to say thank you to someone when they've
given them something but meditating you
can't control it's like you can't force
someone to go to sleep right like that
if that's just not something is there an
optimal or appropriate age to introduce
this my favorite age to teach is nine
and ten and I still generally think
that's the best if there's one time that
you're going to introduce it to children
I think that's the time partly because
it stays with them I think when they
learn around fourth grade those memories
stay with them
yeah and they're also at this really
beautiful stage of still being kids but
they're starting to think like adults
and you can have basically every
conversation you would have with in
adults about meditation with a child
that age and so I think the learning is
just very deep and I think they learn as
well as as younger children but I am
always proven wrong when I think a group
of children are too young and I'm
invited to try to teach them now the
youngest I've taught is four and a half
and they absolutely learned and it's
different you know what each age is
different you and I would say not every
child in that class was meditating for
sure maybe four or five of them caught
it and a couple had some really
interesting experiences so I think they
can learn as young as four I think it
depends on the context on how they're
learning speak about that and just the
Epiphany that one young child had about
what the present moment is else yeah no
that's so often the Epiphany and it's I
love it it's so interesting to hear them
talk about it but yeah this was a little
boy I think he's five or was five at the
time and yeah he I mean he barely had
the language to describe what he was
talking about but it was similar to what
that the other girl in second grade who
I mentioned in my book it's a similar
realization and he talked about it in
terms of it going fast he said it just
keeps going I don't even remember
exactly what he said but it was
something about it moving fast which was
one of the first realizations I had when
I
really got and was able to concentrate
for long enough to kind of stay
moment-to-moment for a significant
period of time if there's something kind
of energizing about it because it really
it is it's it it's a good way to
describe it so moving fast
there's maybe teaching us in schools we
should be teaching it in schools and you
all our schools are in need to
institutionalize this I know that yeah
yes I think we might be headed there
yeah yeah I was not optimistic about
that just five ten years ago and now I
actually think we're headed there
somewhere I now have the opposite
concern which is that's happening too
fast and I don't want programs that
aren't vetted and legit yes yeah all
right we're gonna we gotta land this
plane
but perhaps leave us with all right so
you we've challenged all our intuitions
about consciousness like where where
does this leave us like I finished the
book and I'm like okay now I'm like I'm
I you know what are we you're asking
questions right so what do we do with
these these threads that were pulling on
in terms of how we can how they can
inform how we live our life day to day
yeah I'm not sure I don't ya know
luckily we now have this research
actually that shows that being in a
state of awe is actually very good for
us and there's I mean we kind of can
feel that we know that it feels good but
it's it increases our well-being to to
think about these things in to
contemplate mysteries and the bigger
questions and so I think if anything
there's that there's that you know if
you enjoy wondering about these things
keep doing it I think you know what's
going on think again right right
I love the book it's great the subtitle
is a brief guide to the fundamental
mystery of the mind it is brief it's a
it's a small book but don't be confused
this is this is a very you gotta take
your time you know you're not gonna
rifle through this you could read it in
a short period of time but the concepts
themselves are
are very deep and they're asking you to
think deeply about them which is great
so congratulations I love doing yeah
good how do you feel you feel all right
yeah good we did it yeah thanks so much
if you want to connect with Annika where
the best ways for people to probably my
website is the best is just Annika
Harris comm but it's a tan aka Harris
comm and are you doing any public events
or speaking or any that kind of stuff um
very literal yeah nothing to announce
now although i do i do announce
everything that's coming up on social
media all right good and if you have
children and you're interested in
exploring meditation with them the
waking up app you can find all
hanukkah's programs yes
and some of my guided meditations are on
my website awesome cool thank you yeah
all right peace
[Music]